by now you're probably aware that the
sealed 30 ton black granite sarcophagus
has been opened which was recently
discovered in Alexandria Egypt and made
headlines around the world as everyone
waited to see what would be found inside
and speculation flourished on the
internet and in the news with
suggestions ranging from ancient
Egyptian mummies containing riches and
treasure to the lost remains of
Alexander the Great to even an ancient
curse that would lead to a zombie
apocalypse but what they did find were
the gruesome remains of three mummies or
should I say skulls with their skeletons
along with a disgusting and horrendously
foul odor red sewage which I'll be
discussing and sharing more photos of in
just a moment but first of all there is
way more to this story than the pictures
and the details that were reported by
the news because a few things that they
shared about it just do not add up and
in this video I'm going to connect the
dots and some really interesting
information about this as well as share
additional photos that did make the
headline articles going around the world
on this topic now real quick if you
haven't watched my previous video that I
made before the sarcophagus was opened
be sure to check that out and I'll
include a link pop up at the end of this
video so you can watch it as I discuss
many interesting details that I won't be
mentioning again in this video but one
point that I did make was that the
opening of this sarcophagus should be
done on live TV or through live
streaming which ultimately did not
happen and is a total shame for a
variety of reasons that aside the
process of opening the sarcophagus was
very difficult the pit that it's buried
in is 16 and a half feet or five meters
deep and it's easier to appreciate just
how deep that is when you see pictures
of it and you can see here that they
even tied two ladders together to climb
down into the pit to open the lid which
was sealed with a thick mortar they
utilized wedges to pry it open and then
stack wood in between the lid and the
sarcophagus to elevate it but something
happened as soon as they cracked it open
the smell of the red sewage inside was
so pungent that they had to stop working
and leave the pit in fact the smell was
so bad that at first they thought the
fumes could be lethally toxic
so they put on surgical masks before
we're continuing and in this photo you
can actually see here Mustafa Waziri the
secretary-general of Egypt Supreme
Council of Antiquities being the very
first person to look and see what's
inside this massive stone box and this
here is what he saw the pool of a red
colored sewage that they claimed must
have leaked into the sarcophagus at some
point after it was buried so at this
time they decided to completely remove
the massive 15 tonne lid and when I say
massive you have to compare it to the
size of people to truly appreciate it
but the whole sarcophagus itself
measures nearly nine feet long five and
a half feet wide and six feet tall and
you can see the metric conversion here
in this photo but to lift and remove the
lid they of course to use heavy
machinery a crane to do so and just look
at this lid isn't that thing amazing of
course in my prior video I discussed the
issues involved with cutting and carving
this black granite stone and how bronze
saws as theorized by Egyptologists and
archeologists could not have done this
especially not with this level of
precision and I also mentioned how
archaeologists suggest that ropes and
pulleys were used by the ancients to
lift or lower heavy stones and although
I do not doubt the use of police by the
ancients it must be mentioned that no
police or ropes have ever been found
from the ancient Egyptians that were
large enough or strong enough to have
sustained this level of weight but that
of course does not mean that they didn't
exist either but it's just important for
everyone to see what it takes in modern
times to lift something of this weight a
massive freakin hydraulic crane and
while we're at it look at the
surroundings of where this was found in
the middle of the densely populated city
of Alexandria Egypt so it of course
makes you wonder what else could be
buried in the immediate area around it
what is hidden just meters underneath
these buildings here and don't forget
that this sarcophagus was discovered by
accident by a construction crew working
on a new building but getting back to
the red sewage that was found inside the
sarcophagus it must be mentioned that in
the three weeks since the discovery and
prior to opening it there was no smell
or evidence of sewage within the pit we
all remember the considerable amount of
speculation about what could be hidden
inside and not one single person
involved with this discovery said
anything
about the smell of death emitting from
the sealed box and this not forgets that
they were very specific in stating that
the lid was sealed with thick mortar so
wait a second if sewage was somehow able
to leak into this sealed sarcophagus at
some point which is exactly what they
stated about it why then couldn't they
smell it until after the lid had already
been opened I mean they specifically
stated that it wasn't until after they
pried open the lid that they could smell
it and again we can see that before it
was open nobody was wearing masks and
once they crapped it open they all did I
mean I wasn't there so I obviously do
not know all the details involved but
what makes them so sure that this sewage
came from outside and leaked its way in
because it seems to me that this red
sewage is actually what's left of the
decayed bodily fluids of the three
individuals that they found inside they
of course pumped the fluid out and when
they did this is what you could see
absolutely disgusting right what you're
looking at are the skeletal remains of
three individuals and here are the other
photos provided by Egyptian antiquities
where you can see it from above and also
photos of the three skulls that they
pulled from it so there's a few things
to discuss about this first is that the
only thing inside were the bones and the
fluid nothing else no clothing no
jewelry just bones and sewage and you
can see that came from two different
sources so it sounds like these three
people were essentially naked when they
were put into this box and well I'll
discuss more about that in a second but
Mustafa Waziri also clarified that none
of the mummies belong to the Ptolemaic
period which is about 2300 years ago as
was previously suggested particularly
due to the alabaster head found not far
from this sarcophagus it's been
suggested that the three individuals
could have been warriors or soldiers
during the time of the Pharaohs and they
suggest this due to the trauma to one of
the skulls found which could be from an
arrow through the head obviously this is
all speculation it could be true but we
really have no idea because there was
nothing found in the stone box other
than the bones and what I believe to be
the leftover and decayed bodily fluids
of these three naked dead
people found inside of it additionally
there were no inscriptions or works of
art of any kind within the box or
outside of it which is actually highly
unusual and here you can see a similar
example of a sarcophagus of this kind
and all the incredible hieroglyphs found
both in and outside of it so there are
none found on the newly discovered
sarcophagus and yet various news outlets
are still suggesting that the box is
from the Ptolemaic period which is
certainly ridiculous
it's beyond clear that this box was
reused and the three people found inside
were not the original person or things
meant for it one thing that stood out to
me were the skulls at least one of them
appears to be a bit small and I am by no
means an expert on skeletal remains and
it was actually suggested that this was
perhaps a family burial but maybe these
were young adults a female who knows but
again these people were apparently
buried naked and left with no type of
inscription or marker of any kind on
their grave which is a bit suspicious I
can't help but think that perhaps three
people went missing thousands of years
ago and someone got rid of the bodies in
a way that nobody should ever find them
I mean think about it they were murdered
and dumped naked into the stone box and
it was sealed up the remains are
actually now being moved to the
Alexandria national restoration Museum
where they will be examined to identify
cause of death and possible age and the
sarcophagus is being sent to a military
museum so here is something that you're
pretty much guaranteed to find
disgusting / disturbing remember that
red sewage that they found inside guess
what they decided to do with it they
kept some samples of it to be analyzed
and the rest was literally dumped into
the street and you can actually watch
video of it here on YouTube and you can
even tell when watching it that this
guy's face wreaked of guilt and the
people watching and taking photos around
him and although they were speaking
Arabic and I couldn't understand it it
seemed that they were giving this guy's
[ __ ] for doing what he was doing I mean
pouring the foul liquid remains of human
bodies into the street around their
homes there are so many things wrong
with this and besides the fact that it's
an obvious health issue to the people in
the area but they're also literally
discarding the remain
evidence I don't know how much of this
ancient mummy juice they kept to be
analyzed but this is a profound example
of the reckless negligent behavior on
behalf of the Egyptian antiquities and
excavations do you see what I mean
with all of this said it will be
interesting to see pictures of this
sarcophagus once it is cleaned out but
it really makes you wonder it was
originally inside of it clearly this
thing was reused and there is certainly
way more to the story than meets the eye
I mean think about what an incredible
mystery this is people went to an
incredible extent to cut in carve this
stone block which was more than sixty
six thousand pounds or more than 30
metric tons all to just dump three naked
bodies in it with no inscription of any
kind no no no no there is way more to
this story than meets the eye like I
said earlier and I'm very curious to see
what your thoughts are so definitely
leave me a comment and share what your
insight is on this but I'll leave it at
that hit the like button and subscribe
but I'm Jimmy this is bright insight and
I have many more videos to come and a
whole wide variety of topics take care
of everybody